a ball is dropped from a look-out a
hundred and eighty meters high okay so
there's our lookout and there he is he's
got a ball in his hand and he drops it
okay so that's the first part at the
same time a stern is fired vertically
upwards from the valley floor what did
we say was a valley it's a valley now
okay great
suppose I should make this Mill Valley
like Haggard's a valley there's a
sub-sub projectile weapon on the ground
and a fire just thrown upwards with
speed V you go wait hold on it's fired
upwards I failed visual arts all right
take G equals 10 meters per second
squared so we've got at the same time
and same time we have a force acting
downwards on this
okay now this is kind of what I love
about situations like this it's such a
simple setup
such a simple setup it's all I have to
give you 60 million equations all of the
information is so in there
it's all there okay now what do they ask
us fine for what values of V a collision
in the air will occur all right pause
what's that mean fine for what values of
V a collision will occur what's going on
what they think you are well thankfully
I still have this with me well I should
have brought a rock from outside anyway
so ball falls down right okay this will
just have to do as a rock okay all fours
daddy gets dropped okay and at the same
time the rockets fight upward okay now
obviously if the rock doesn't get fired
up with stone if the storm doesn't get
fired up would add enough of velocity
right for example if I just throw it up
like you know just do that
hardly any velocity right it's not it's
gonna hit back above the ground it's not
gonna go high enough to hit the ball the
balls gonna come down right and this is
going to go up and then go down and
there's gonna be no collision right and
they're just going to land on the floor
okay if I hit it if I fire fast enough
right you know then they'll actually hit
before this starts coming back down to
the ground they'll hit somewhere in the
middle somewhere yeah okay sir for what
values of V will the collision occur I
try to work out what's the lowest this
could be that they'll actually collide
okay there's the first question then
find in terms of V the time in the
height where the collision occurs prove
that the collision speed is V meters a
second okay right yeah let's just say
what is the first question um we're
looking for a for what values it's an
inequality we're after right it's not a
V equals this value okay it's gonna be a
range of some kind okay so we're looking
for something like this right I assume
it has to be greater than zero right
some kind of inequality like that such
that a collision occurs where have you
look at motion right
it's straight line motion a straight
line motion so there are three
quantities that we keep track of in
straight line motion three quantities
and three quantities only right
what are they three quantities that
change admittedly I've got two objects
but you just think about each one on its
own right you should know about
displacement right what else can you
tell me that velocity and acceleration
generally all in respects at the time
right now
he's my question to you I'm interested
in a collision right which of these
three objects will tell me about a
collision it'll be about displacement
right I don't care if they're traveling
at the same speed I don't care if the
same force is actually on them I want to
know where they are at the same place
right so therefore I need to get some
equations for X for each of these two
things I have pictured to some of you
that um you don't necessarily need to do
it in terms of two equations you can do
it in terms of one so I would normally
just carry on but my voice just kind of
take it today so that's why waiting I'm
going to show you how to do with two
equations okay like I said you don't
have to you can think about what
equation they believe the distance
between the two objects and then solve
it for that want it to be zero okay but
it's just as easy I think to think of it
in terms of two equations just so long
as you keep them separate so you've got
six equations you don't mix them up okay
so if I want to get to displacement
equations right I'm going to get two I'm
gonna get one for a little ball up here
like B for ball and s for stone okay so
therefore I've got the displacement of
the ball right and I've got the
displacement of the stone and I want to
know when they are equal to each other
okay that's what I'm after but in order
to get there well yeah I don't have a
displacement equation okay all I've got
is this right I know an initial velocity
for this I also know even though it
didn't get told to you I know an initial
velocity for the ball what is it it's
zero the word that tells you that is the
word dropped right so as opposed to you
know thrown so I actually put some speed
into it if I drop it at time zero well
at that time it's not going anywhere
right so I got an initial condition for
the velocity for both of them and then I
have this guy a force right an
acceleration that's constantly acting on
the situation so I may need to start
from there and climb up the ladder that
makes sense
all right let's do this first let's
consider the ball okay now by the way
it's crucial I've been the same as to a
few of you pilot kids on my mind cuz I'm
marking some of your papers right is
crucial crucial crucial particular
topping for this right that you set out
things clearly you have so many
questions and so many values flying
around okay you cannot hope to just sort
of check them all out there and I hope
that the pile will make sense on its own
okay so layout is part of mathematical
communication I don't think it below you
because you're the top class you need to
still make sure that everything you say
is clearly laid out okay so the ball its
deceleration now I haven't said anything
about where things are in terms of like
I am the coordinate system yet so I need
to put one in so what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna call the valley for I'm gonna
call that zero you don't have to you
could call a look at zero if you wanted
and everything would be negative I just
don't like negatives so that's why I
called the zero which makes that
positive 180 okay that'll come in in a
second now therefore if that's what I've
called a sorry that's not a call done by
the origin and that's gonna go up there
right there for a is going to be
negative right because it's going
downwards okay like I said if you
flipped everything it will be positive
okay it's gonna be negative ten their
supply to value for
for us right now it's important that you
get that a that's dv/dt right that's
function of time you know it's a
function of time because the use for
your acceleration our time units meters
per second right
so don't mix this up with what we look
at before and functions of displacement
so if want to go from here climb up the
ladder to velocity right I should
integrate with respect to time right
that'll give me V yeah you do great DV
DT with respect to T so you get this
right we're gonna have a lot of Costas
flying around so maybe they're courting
late okay now this is the ball right I
suppose if you want to make this really
clear maybe you don't like having
headings like this you call this a B and
V be right but it's indicate what you're
talking about now how do I work out what
this class that is we have an initial
condition don't we
okay namely at time 0 right that's time
zero this velocity is zero right another
thing on Leia I've seen quite a few of
you I suppose because comment baby I do
it sometimes as well put stuff like this
initial conditions put it up over here
because like this is kind of peripheral
to my idea I see what you mean but try
to avoid doing that I want to be able to
read down this thing especially what I'm
going to have something else running
parallel to it okay
that's that so therefore I could say
this okay and I can get my constant
okay so far so good
by the way what does that mean look as
time progresses the Varsity gets faster
and faster the negative Directorate done
it that makes sense because that's what
you inspected to do right okay
that's while city I need to go one
further step and get the displacement so
you get to great again and we've seen
this right we've seen this a hundred
times I pointed out to you when I first
introduced it that you'll see this over
and over again because of this constant
coming up over every go okay
plus it look Austin right okay how do I
allow at this closet the same way I did
the previous one namely with an initial
condition this is the boss so he starts
up there okay so that gives you constant
for that as well
okay this is good this is progress now I
know at any time where the ball is and
how fast it's going
that's good let's think about a stone
okay what force is acting on the stone
the same one that was acting on the ball
right so in fact it's acceleration
function AMS is the same it's still
negative ten right but when you
integrate up to get the velocity of the
stone right you've got a new constant
the fourth one sorry the third one but
my count okay and this guy's different
because we have a different initial
condition and it's capital v all right
there's another reason why it's useful
to subscript these so you know what
you're talking about okay so that time
zero right the velocity of the stone is
capital v bigger and that is the only
time its capital v the second it starts
going not even the s/m secondly whatever
is the smallest unit
it's not gonna be capital v anymore cuz
we'll slow down because of this guy
should have said slow down but you get
the idea
so therefore hot right when I evaluate
this cost at time 0 you're just going to
get this that's the third constant keep
climbing up let's go to displacement
still got the same minus 5t squared
there ah but no discuss things here
right
plus there you go here's my constant
so if that's a good what's the initial
condition for this he starts on the
valley floor right okay so therefore I
get this equation cool so now I know at
any given time T where the stirring is
and where the ball is and now I just
want the two collide right okay now this
is interesting
watch what happens you know what these
two two collide yes so you say x equals
x yes right so then you get this here's
X B and here is X yes right all I've
done is just write down the equations
right by the way for what it's worth
this is where your two equation has
become my equation this is my one
equation that will solve this right
you've got a negative 5t squared on both
sides so you say okay fine what does
this mean I'm not gonna feed you this
answer yet because at this point this is
where we get confused we think wait what
am i after again now clearly clearly
you're actually in this equation you
want t because capital V is just a
number it's a constant something I don't
know what it is but it's just a number
right so therefore you get this now hold
on a second hold on I wanted to know
some restriction on V that would tell me
will they collide or not right but this
is not at all a restriction on V what is
this what does this time represent this
time this is when these positions are
the same the displacement is the same of
course it's wet because these equations
are in terms of time so this will tell
you when the two objects hit each other
that's that's nice that's good
information but it's not the answer
all right how do I get an answer like
this out of this I'm gonna let you ever
think about it I've heard you get
through a lot of this right we'll add a
new juncture just like we were when I
wrote this down where now you've got to
think now what is my next step if I told
you what the next step was right now I
would rob you of the experience of
actually working it out yourself okay so
I'm gonna give you some time to see if
you can think what now I've gotten to
this wall how do I climb over it or
where do I even claim to I know some of
you on the right track to have a thing
give it a go if you think you're near to
call me elf